this right hey it started this top 32
and losers because of Allah they were in
the same pool yeah let him go out beat
him to 1 so it's you know a K had to
work that it's higher toddler did you
just again his run back yes and again
just like Evo Japan is Philippines vs.
Pakistan man oh yeah yeah right but this
time the both of us yeah who all the
loser sided you know I feel like a cane
and especially you know this is kind of
the general thing is that I feel like
when players are playing in the loser's
bracket and doing well they can carry
that momentum with them yeah usually
just carried all the way but right now
both of these guys are on winning
momentum the law hasn't lost and aka
hasn't lost since losing to plow in
Falls he's been on a tear below right
now is getting maybe he's a little bit
whole now he's been sitting back but
this time he has not gone for the Akuma
mera he is locked in which in here
versus below grand finals time at
Pakistan vs. Philippines is gonna be a
great one man
alright guys pop quiz Hot Shots this
goes for the people at home to stream
make some noise if you want bulow to
take great finals they go for you guys
out there too okay but if you guys would
like a que to take grand finals stream
crown make some noise
[Applause]
thanks for participating guys there's
definitely a few people that screaming
for both but anyway let's get into it
I mean sometimes you gotta you know you
gotta fill them both a and B on the
bottle under hope that the a quick start
from both guys okay with the Celilo feet
here
get the bass right you get the drop on
[Music]
the down for a cage our first blood here
in the match up against a castle in two
sets that is gonna be easy right the law
has gone through almost every up
actually he's gone through every
opponent that he's placed thus far yeah
so if you guys are not familiar because
a case from the new decide he needs to
win to first two trees here he's well on
his way here with one round has a lot of
momentum as well all these loser bracket
matches good combo here great carry as
well gets anything you can do I can do
better I can jump to Brody I love this
patients so far from the line and host
oppressively Mary Kate has been his whip
are teaching so far yeah yeah
visibility distal and certain moves I'm
whether it's down forward to or even the
hop kick it just impeccable hmm I feel
like one of the things that's made him
better overall as a player is his pacing
that's been lets him know when to pull
the trigger I'll be like you're I'm
gonna go slides over and over I'm gonna
go for these hop cakes all be over yeah
I know already seems I'm very very
strong [ __ ] their Bulow answers back
with one second left one round apiece
yeah like I said there's a lot of strong
Akuma plays that are sorted age from the
Philippines as well so it's not like
they have a good practice
a k.will half practice that's the
character y'all see users account of
course is Bob up in LA with two parts
they need to work with can't use the one
you getting combo zone
became it on the wall oh but the rain to
get yeah man this is gonna be a close
one I feel it yeah in bailout seems like
you're just trying to make get to this
ball yeah listen fresh on a cake you're
gonna have to try and punish a K for use
in those down for Tuesday's well you
know use the standing to stop him from
using that and now I mean think about it
like this
a K playing a cool now I feel like it's
understanding of this matchup
yeah alright try Chris but ain't able to
take match number one and I seem to be
in his favor that's a very good example
of why you to finish your compost I know
Cuba's comas are very hard but that
would have been the round therefore
Milan stead a K gets the match first
blood on the board now what does the
last you hair does he go straight in I
mean he's got but you did win asthma so
just hit straight revenge okay another
thing I feel like even though he also
plays a cool I feel like he's been using
a coolant to kind of get a feel right I
feel like it's a great check the
temperature you know carry it let you
know what this guy's strong Bob really
good to let me see how they deal with
this Akuma stuff like that's a thing
that I felt like a K has done amazingly
so far this weekend and look at where
it's got gotten to this grand finals in
the LCQ one of the hardest echod
tournaments ever you know like those
things we mean a lot because we're
looking at the highest possible play for
taking right now and this is the person
that's turning around has a new
character with Akuma and look at his
understanding of a problem matchup for
the world
yeah no definitely definitely you got
done the homework man they're not
messing about here they came here to win
and you know if for this kind of
tournament you know even in the finals
tomorrow let's say they say that a K
does win whoever wins you know you're
gonna find a clue mahalia there's gonna
be an Akuma C hafta than your homework
and you signed it did as well out of the
entire community looks like a lot of
people didn't do their homework at least
in the matchup I mean Japan came in hard
they were able to be you know one of the
best Akuma players in that team yes and
it's just insane to see I mean even I
musician he I mean special case right
yeah he's he's a special player I mean
only
Yoshimitsu at that level I would say for
sure yeah Wow he's gonna go to the Brian
oh it looks like he is yeah this looks
like the set is changing even faster
than I thought it would yes after one
match already we see this matchup I
expected you know honestly I expect to
see Akuma come early on yeah but I don't
think he wants to wait until the second
set to actually make the change maybe
he's trying to think here what works I
want to know what works what doesn't
work early on make him bleed early you
want to don't wanna you don't want to
drag this out especially with the way a
Kay is playing I feel like he's
speedrunning now like he matches now you
know he's more than warmed up
he's already fought you once he has in a
coma and now you're switching characters
and he has to play from loser side a Kay
is looking good definitely but allow is
allowing the same we're gone right we've
seen him make some clutch comebacks and
he's a thinker he'll take the time in
between that match to make sure he
understands what's going on and make the
curve to switch a baby and there's right
look at that side step with the down for
to in close towards doing West's book as
well you're gonna get the corner
pressure here I'll take the okiya stay
nice
I smell conversion Oh doesn't try to go
for it yeah Wow just does it you have
just thumbs it out I like that just to
kind of had a feeling I'm gonna step in
right now yeah okay has a lot of
confidence in his in his ability to
download timing as well it looks like
you know he's been catching people were
down for two a lot day just like you
know I know you're gonna come in yeah
he's definitely that kind of player
would smells like you know it looks like
he's just throwing things out but it's
not that she hasn't feel that you're
gonna step in right then yes should be
noted that mean ache a very comfortable
in this matchup I mean he's played
against some of the best Brian players
in both mister naps and Annie as well
and he was able to beat him right Wow
yeah everlaw's you know even though his
the who has been really strong lately
just in this top end it feels like he's
been using a lot of lotta pride mmm he
did say to me that if the humid in a
truck you know he'd go to Brian when he
needs you but look at that geez he's
just what if we did it yeah I believe
that landed for back to out Milton why
not and that's the thing is what a cane
starts doing things like that when he
starts playing with that level or that
are of disrespect he's in a good mood
he's feeling himself yes look at it he's
feeling himself right now yeah he's done
punch Mary and it has a hit once yeah
but that's just shows how confident he
is he's just throwing up gang signs like
he likes to do it it's in a very good
job of making beloved out himself as
well he does all a will walk him you see
Pilates he's scared okay he put that
down for two
[Music]
this is he's gonna have to do something
here yeah he finishes the string doesn't
if there's a plot more ducky yeah well I
didn't looking for that with punish but
a K is he gonna give it to him 10
seconds left look he's got to do
something
oh yes be careful oh he was so focused
on landing the tot mix-up that he ate
the get up kick that's just unfortunate
there hmm what is what is Balazs you now
- stage select he wants to stage like
he's sticking with grinding yeah just
even though he'd seem like he did worse
that's that game it seems like this he's
confident in that in that match yeah
wonder why I would love to talk to him
just to see like his thought process
especially after what you say right like
the fact that you telling me he's one of
the most successful tournament players
the impact is saying I would love to
like pick his brain and see how he
thinks like I said before that's why I'm
really upset I didn't get the gold to
Pakistan because I wanted to talk to a
bunch of the players see how they feel
about certain matchups yes they're
police tiles in general it's cool
talking to though because they're there
their whole outlook on Tekken is very
simplistic it's so simplistic and
compared to other people who were like
this
over complicate things you know but
sometimes you need to man keep it simple
but yeah can be law pretty Bassett it
looks like he hasn't been able to gather
much information he's lost two games
we've very one-sided yeah we'll see dojo
those smaller stage shift flower but
still has one more center right below
now looking too good right now put this
could all be data right I mean it might
not be the easiest data to collect but
its data nonetheless for sure now back
to so belong playing a very positive
placed on man he's trying to wait for
any whiff punished
against a K but I can't don't give it to
him this is like you don't want a K
feeling yourself this much I mean
obviously he's looking Larry now he then
he's on the verge of maybe making a
reset here with the type of confidence
that he's giving him here he's getting
fit lots of swingers law this ain't good
- yeah it's really crazy cuz Paul just
has
closing the distance all that well yeah
you could've that stuff man you know Dre
I hope this town for twos and down Ford
was the way he's been doing this
negative really hard to get it even mr.
watt to switch sides
terrifying rage available P loss has to
do something years get around on the
board man and look how much it is to
take a screen he doesn't care
yeah he's chillin now three completely
with quick sidewalk card you so great to
do that versus okay try to get there one
more time but look at that one more
round for a to reset the entire grant
fine just like that 3-0
Grand Finals reset now Bulow solution
that was the quickest reefs I've seen in
a while a long time about of a
three-round match real if you're belong
here what do you do do you pick a kuma
do you go back to the character can I go
out to kill my match I would yeah I mean
it just depends on how he feels about
the second because right now a K is
playing out of his mind
yeah I think we can tell for sure is
brightness but working yeah that's
definitely it isn't look ultimately I
know like a lot of times are like yo man
you want to you have to think about like
how you feel right but sometimes as a
player that death is can get you
destroyed an eternal you can triple like
not oh no I got this and doubling down
can get you in trouble
I like for Lyle taking this time you're
sitting here sit on it you got some time
you got on now you're in the this is the
end game now
well the set is about to come to an end
and
LCQ is about to be over you got to
change something so Bilal has been take
very passively waiting for an
opportunity to with punish and he hasn't
been able to get it every time you throw
out the down for to he's let a kid get
away with it with a kuba
I've seen this matchup before where
people can actually reach punished if
using the right range with standing to
and it's something that belong is good
at doing right he just hasn't done it
yet so if he can do that if you can pick
a creamer and actually utilize that and
make a cape out himself then he could
win this and the thing is he's done it
before yeah he just has to do it again
I don't know what that first set was he
was obviously feeling the comfort of
having you know one set to go but that
is gone and that was gone way faster
than we thought oh yeah
facts oh that you can see it below right
now yeah precious gang to it yeah it's a
body language of both of these players
right now
all right alex has told them it looks
like I think he's going to a coach right
either a coach or looks like
hey kids ready to go yeah okay is
definitely ready to go but man this
isn't a portable because again only one
of these two players will make it so
tomorrow yeah it comes out to this
rested this first two three right here
man who's gonna be in the tech world
tour finals tomorrow okay open la
Pakistan or the Philippines it's
definitely gonna be in time I can tell
you that right now
yeah because aks is looking unstoppable
he's downloaded everyone's timing so
well I mean you look at the everyone
thinks okay these Hopkins's is random
these down 4-2 isn't just random no he's
not he's reading when you're gonna copy
and you see the little girl that was not
random that was all right here
destruction oh yes we had spats cuz his
down for two hits like it he went like 9
out of 10 like it was so good I mean but
look at what it does form like in
another conversation we were having
earlier
it's like those clash of styles that's
one of the things I love most about
watching high-level taken because we get
so many territories that are represented
in these Styles all clash because each
territory plays different here and I've
been trying to tell so many people that
like me right now why I'm taking so hot
right now why is the Pakistan thing such
a thing it's because they play
completely different we have these
established known styles from every
region and once they clash that's the
tournament and this is what you get from
it you get high-intensity matches like
this with some of the best players in
the world
and some of the upcoming best players in
the world my boy a K but Lau you said
before he's live and as he's already
been in the tournament scene what's the
bride like wow he's thinking of Brian no
demons today damn I mean me I mean it's
tilt me out of five yeah it sounds like
it seems like he might have got a little
bit of coaching some baby he's gone
because it seems like he's so confident
in this pic he how strong can you you
saw how bad it was yeah horse but but
what else you have yeah that's right he
beautiful Takuma before but that was
that was also any case' cool yeah who's
the mirror the heavy go can belong make
the comeback head what did he get from
his coach find out now we'll find out
what it was yeah we're about to fire the
coach
you go talk to your coach look man I'm
tapped down I don't really know what to
tell you all right open stage to see how
this is gonna play out but obviously
less damage overall for Brian it's not
gonna be able to get a lot of the open
setups yeah but she gained some of those
decent damage and open doesn't work that
doesn't work but Mantha reactions there
from a K that was nice yeah and she he
gets so much damage in the open now in
season three of every single launch the
grand finals is it the final set of the
tournament yep we've been at this for
almost ten hours usually or over ten
hours
so much taking action and again back
back for actually hits oh my god this is
tense this is tense rage drive available
ake a threatening it yes I like that I
like that blood just Pig patient yeah
even though it seems like lungs out of
it right he's in the lead at this in the
grand final technical yeah he's in the
lead right now so yeah I mean he's
definitely being a little bit more
aggressive we saw last time he was
bought but you know have you got just
counting hit by a cake and I swear I've
seen so many counter hit get up threes
yeah this one tournament that the entire
yeah we usually tell new players not to
do get up kick super easy they know the
timing man yeah they're watching this
like he's making a Super Bowl [ __ ] on
now he's just back dashing he's got
delightfully huge lack need yeah if he's
gonna jammer when he comes in
oh my god anyone for the house he's
crazy yeah doesn't go fight he gets
punished up and down for two
and it's because he slows down a little
bit right not overextending because a
lot of times he was getting counter him
now he's playing a little slower he's in
rage and only ten seconds left great
still one plus two
what you gonna do full-on rage though
he's gonna give him the rate drive and
the rager but all he gets dude he needs
to get a hit but there's no time left
Oh check your pockets I got it man he
pulled them there right at the very end
go ahead Steve I know you're feeling in
here we'll keep these again but just
outside of this is they're not able to
get the conversion and that's been
problematic I mean that's happened quite
a few times
master of the rain without on the
follow-up you tried to wit punish it
down forward one yeah get a little bit
yeah they're likely to get but he's
gonna have to be very wary it jumps yep
oh boy do it again Oh doesn't commit 20
seconds left on the clock
aka rage life will allow finally stop to
the street and get the first game of
this reset here in Grand Finals oh man I
don't know about y'all that was the
hardest wat three straight rounds I've
seen in a long time yeah those are
nail-biters each and every time what an
amazing feat from Vlado to get body like
that with with Brian and then bring it
back to here and straight that's
impressive
yeah but I ain't over yet I mean
whatever advice you got he must have
been getting oh my god he won the match
this is how stress will take you give me
some time you need your eyes stick your
fingers this is the first time that
belong on the huge stage like this we're
like this is taking well talk LCQ this
is for finals man ya know it's exactly
how our salon looked at Evo Japan as
well because nobody winning and this is
what I look like I'm seeing the thinking
man poles this is thinking man poles it
just goes out as long as we're back here
where we have walls so there you're not
gonna be able to run the whole time wow
what a wimp Harnish I can yeah this kid
is insane
Jenny's pace in this set has been sold
nice to see know it's like you know slow
down then - back - real fast and all of
a sudden he's doing a slide picks up
yeah yeah
he's in the air and he's doing the
slight motion yeah it's great he's
buffering the slide oh there it is yeah
do it again
sequence oh he Big Ben in a my side
space and he's white he has four in
round Street now over aka he's gonna
have to start doing something here he
was playing with so much confidence
earlier I think he just needs that one
round well then whatever coach told him
his work yeah he did take the coach's
advice way and it's also he iced a key a
little bit you also have to take that
into consideration
yeah truth breaks to throw nice
confirmed or he has another wall to
what's gonna do boy caught up with the
mid yep always ready
he's just so ready ready to paint her
man look at the declarations he says I
displayed this is crazy how much that
will be hanging out of his house yeah
the Blues is dragging over Ernie I can't
move five brown straight for faith bill
on over a K here that first set looks
like a long gone
yeah I feel like that was last season
yeah hey that was last ewt we still they
broke in the wolf we're about to break
one right now
[Laughter]
they'll show me some succulents won't
break another 100k gallons mother's sake
dad took off but on a damn it today but
this is where villas shut it started to
shape every time in rage he's always
been able to catch dry doesn't go for
the bait drive below this is amazing one
that much away potential last match
right here if we'll all continues
playing like this a can't well you can
tell us a little shaking up up there
right now to doing so great net first
set right yeah guys this is Tekkit as a
true this is second you know what
happened a me it's all about the play
this is crazy the way he got bodied in I
lost a point about six round straight
high level second ladies and last what
you know it's some good ticket man hell
yes exactly why I love taking out of our
group here - we were having a discussion
earlier about who we feel was gonna win
the tournament no one picked below no
that's true so he is really uh making a
name for himself a mighty name here but
it's not over yet okay if you can get
the momentum we know he's an event to
bass player he could do this yeah he won
the last at 3:02 so yeah wouldn't be
outside of the field house I belong
can't get comfortable like he was last
set you might have a too much lead but
it's not over yeah for sure
he's backing up yeah there has to be an
adjustment here from make a you know he
can't be pulling the same way obviously
so yeah yeah and you can tell right now
that momentum is just all home sad from
a k and it's book people's place
in opening up a k7r out straight bit
long is looking like a piece two rounds
away from qualifying for the Tucker
World Tour Finals yeah and again if you
got to remind everyone he is stuck now
with Shaheen he has to use Shaheen for
the rest of the tournament oh that's
true good she hit a ton of work early on
so I like I like the decision just a
grand final last time talking about seen
everything better see a snake edge
tomorrow I'll do it
hey they won't be on purpose but
hopefully over the patient's right now
no one wasn't make any commitment take
it has a small life lead yeah I mean
it's a big it's a big commitment here
right here this could be this could be
two rounds to none or tied up Oh what's
gonna happen there it is again iqcp
three time's wasting
oh my gosh you just blow five seconds
that's a clock eight rounds uncontested
Wow Billa one round away Pakistan will
they make it to the finals going to the
point handful pillow LCQ point the a k
IG finally drop the cowboy at the wall
now bad position he's gonna have to be
careful get her down to completely pull
back Oh guys punishment belong now play
out of his mind he's seen the light at
the end of the tunnel he has a lightly -
he's seen that ticket to Sunday will he
get it the Willie be able to have that
shiny piece of paper that guarantees him
a spot in our top 20 oh my gosh he's
fighting hard he's fighting hard to go
either way
I'm so nervous right next kick you do
this
oh he's enraged now he's going to be
careful oh I thought he was gonna cook
with that to reach river there's one 15
seconds left
there's no time he's not over it's not
over definitely over that was the first
round
he's won in a long time he needed it
could be it could very well be the
momentum that he really needed right now
Oh count hit here we go in the back no
that was at the back again though
Rach available what's gonna happen what
he could do it for either player red
dress take the LCQ 2019 hand I've moved
into tomorrow's finals he will be
representing Pakistan tomorrow in the
final leg the gentlemen allow fades
Bilal oh yeah what an amazing set there
to finish off day number what a kayra
saying the break in such a convincing
fashion and then below with a convincing
fashion Batman this is high-level we
have it sat down for the past two rounds
it is it's a we have been here a long
words we gotta get over the a K from the
Philippines second place yo guys yes
guys guys please make some noise for my
boy a K representing the Philippines
what a joy this twt season but you gotta
make some noise for your LCQ champion
it's gonna be but well ladies Jenner
will make some noise damn damn
you know what he didn't do me the kuma
only he stuck with a birthday you're
taken actually I was just character best
and were able to pull it off
what a great showing and we have three
Pakistani players in our finals for
tomorrow it's ridiculous
Pakistan making a notice right now let
everybody know me it was just one a cook
last year in comparison last year there
were no Pakistani players in our top 20
yeah and what a change from this year
yeah really changing the Tekken scene
the competitive scene and just overall
Tekken in general man this is great
never a bad thing to get all yeah this
badge were tomorrow yeah Alton he's like
don't lose that or else you can't come
in the building and we can't let you
play so we must remember falada is not
only a top second player in Pakistan he
is a huge community member recently he
looked after me when he came down here
to - to Pakistan he's a really great guy
overall really really happy for him man
but Wow today wasn't safe